So funky!
Thank you for the gift!
We just started?
Thank you!
Hello everybody!
Funky!
It's so yellow!
Hello!
Welcome to Calorie Mate Liquido!
I don't know what to expect of this at all.
Yay!
Okay, I have something to admit.
I might have said this before on stream.
I have tried... not Calorie Mate Liquid.
I don't even think I can have Calorie Mate Liquid.
Because I think it's carbonated.
So I don't even think I can have it.
But I tried the Calorie Mate...
So I've tried solids, right?
I've tried this Calorie Mate solid.
But I tried the Calorie Mate jelly.
And I tried the... what's it called?
Flavor.
If you ever have had Calorie Mate before...
It has like a distinct Calorie Mate flavor.
Like there's flavors.
Like there's like chocolate and cheese and maple.
And everything like that.
But I tried the jelly one.
And it was...
Yogurt.
Yogurt flavored.
And oh my god.
It's horrible.
Oh my god.
I thought...
I thought I was gonna throw up.
Just having it.
It's so bad.
Never have Calorie Mate jelly yogurt flavor.
Oh my god.
Because it tastes like regular Calorie Mate.
Which is like a biscuit.
Right?
And...
There goes my sponsorship.
But I've never had the Calorie Mate liquid before.
Maybe it's okay.
Maybe it's good.
Who knows?
Oh god.
It's just so gross.
It's so bad.
Maybe the other flavors are better.
But the yogurt one...
Oh my gosh.
It was just...
And then the consistency of the jelly.
It's so gross.
So...
Don't have it.
They're all really gross.
O'Brien says they're all gross.
All the jelly ones?
Now, if you ever want to try Calorie Mate the biscuit...
It's pretty good.
It's actually quite tasty for something if you need.
I especially like that the Calorie Mate biscuits have like...
Little...
Little like...
Piece chunks in them.
It's pretty good.
The biscuits are good.
But don't have the jellies.
Now for the liquids?
I don't know.
Never even heard of them.
Calorie Mate?
Oh my gosh.
Calorie Mate...
Saved me...
When I went to an idol show one time.
Because...
Essentially...
My favorite group was at the end of the day.
And I got there at the beginning of the day.
So I waited...
Like six or seven hours...
Trying to get to the front row...
Of my favorite group.
And so...
Hi, Minto.
Hello.
Hello, hello.
And so...
Throughout the day...
I would...
Like kind of like...
Squat in the theater.
And I would just like...
Eat Calorie Mate.
And then I would stand up...
And I would cheer for more idols.
And then I would squat...
And eat more Calorie Mate.
So...
Yeah...
Calorie Mate is great for events like that.
You know?
Just like Naked Snake.
I know.
I probably look just like him.
I bet there were some people that were like...
Oh my gosh.
That...
That ghost over there?
Well, as long as they have a sixth sense.
You know?
They would have to...
They probably were just like...
I am sensing someone...
Reenacting...
Metal Gear Solid 3.
At this moment.
Imagining Minto and a survival viewer...
Reviewing each of the flavors...
Was pretty tasty.
And this is horrible.
Wait.
This is an actual game?
Yes!
I'm shocked.
There is no like...
You know how...
TM.
Trademark or...
Trademarks exist in Japan, right?
There is no like...
Copyright.
Anything here.
It even has trophies apparently.
Jumping Professional.
Try touching the balloon.
I guess you'll know what this means when the time comes.
So, you know...
It won't let me look at any other trophies.
That's it.
This is the one.
Balloons?
Stop.
Yeah, but you don't have to touch the balloon.
We just have to try and do it.
Good job, Voss, on the many streams.
Calorie legend.
Thank you.
Ice monkey.
I want to play balloons.
No, but we're here for Calorie Mate.
Oh my gosh, my eyes.
So, a few other things.
Yes, I do know that if you play in Nihongo, that the Japanese voice is Akio Otsuka.
A.K.A.
the Japanese voice of Snake.
But...
I decided...
Yoshi, happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Yoshi.
Happy birthday!
I'm going to turn down the volume just a little bit more.
It's so loud.
Maybe like that.
Okay.
Um...
But, uh...
What was I saying?
I decided I'll play it in English.
Because I kind of want to know what's going on.
And I don't want to have to...
If there's anything that I, you know...
I'm not...
I'm not so Nihongo-Jozu, you guys.
So I wouldn't be able to translate everything.
And...
So I wouldn't be able to explain everything.
And, you know...
All that.
And my head is empty.
So...
Japan language, please.
If you went to play Calorie Mate Liquid for yourself, it's free on Steam.
Thank you for waiting!
Thanks, Cheki!
Thank you for the donation!
It's not sponsored, but you can play it and if you want to hear...
Otsuka Akio-sama, in all his snake glory.
And it's really great because he says, And I'm like, you can't have him just saying like that!
You can't just have Solid Snake saying liquid.
But, to counteract the fact that probably it's not David Hayter...
voicing the guy in this Calorie Mate game, which seems like an absolute travesty.
Just seems like a real...
What's the word?
A real blunder on their part.
I instead have got this.
Hey!
Oh my god!
It's really loud.
Hi, Snake!
How are you doing?
I'm good!
How are you?
Are you there?
Yeah!
I'm here!
Who are you?
Oh!
I'm Minto!
Um...
Yeah, I brought you here.
I brought you here, Snake, to be able to do the...
What are you doing here?
This is my channel.
I brought you here to...
Does the name Deep Throat mean anything to you?
Don't answer that.
This is Snake.
So, I have this to help us...
Um...
Uh...
Instead, we can use this...
To counter...
Counter the person that might be doing the narration in this game instead!
Yippee!
Yes.
Yes!
Yeah.
Yeah!
Okay, but what's so funny about this soundboard...
Is I don't know why there's so many...
So many options about him being lonely.
Like...
I'm feeling lonely.
Oh my god.
I'm lonely.
I'll call if I'm feeling lonely.
Why are there so many things about him being lonely?
I don't understand.
You are so cooked.
I discovered this like...
Just earlier, right before stream.
And I bet you can guess what I've been doing...
I've just been like... pressing all of them, you know?
There was another one.
Hold on.
I think it was... oh, wait.
Where is the corpses?
Oh, here we go.
What's this pile of corpses?
Pile of corpses.
Remix.
What's this pile of corpses?
Pile of corpses.
Fire.
I know.
Fingers is quaking in his boots.
Fingers.
I got a new remix for you.
What's this pile of corpses, pile of corpses, pile of corpses.
I love this one too.
Fox is dead.
He's dead.
Now he's dead too.
Fox is dead.
He's dead.
Now he's dead too.
Mint original song.
Okay, okay.
I have this.
So, yes, we'll have fun with it.
We'll be silly goofy as we always are.
Let's start.
Balanced food.
Sorry.
I had an empty cup.
And I just knocked it off my desk from waving my hands around.
Sorry.
I'm very... I talk with my hands very much.
Okay.
Let's start.
Balanced food.
Calorie mate.
Liquid for gamer creators.
I'm liquid.
Calorie mate liquid fruit mix flavor.
I'm...
I'm so...
I'm liquid.
Calorie mate liquid yogurt flavor.
Oh god.
No.
See.
Don't drink this.
It's so bad.
Use code BOOMER for 20% off.
Oh yeah.
BOOMER SUPS.
I'm liquid.
Calorie mate liquid cafe au lait flavor.
Wait.
They don't have...
I'm liquid.
Calorie mate liquid yogurt flavor.
They're all... three of them are maxed out.
I'm liquid.
Calorie mate liquid cafe au lait flavor.
Wait.
I got this.
Hold on.
I've got this.
Liquid snake.
I'm liquid.
Calorie mate liquid fruit mix flavor.
It's so loud.
Liquid snake.
Actually, hold on.
I'm gonna do this instead so I can...
Sorry.
I'm trying to adjust audio stuff.
This should be good.
This should be good, I think.
Sorry.
Okay.
I'm liquid.
Calorie mate liquid fruit mix flavor.
Liquid snake.
It's still so loud.
This is snake.
It's so loud.
Kind of sounds like liquid.
Just a little bit.
I don't know.
This is snake.
Let's do my least favorite.
Calorie mate liquid yogurt flavor.
Liquid in all caps too.
How do I... hold on.
Okay.
Start.
Let's start the game.
Got it.
Sorry.
I'm so obnoxious.
I'm so sorry.
Okay.
Time for a little pre-mission exercise.
Why is there a heartbeat?
And here we go.
What?
Wait.
I didn't even get to read the instructions.
It was so fast.
Wait, wait, wait.
What's the controls?
According to data, the target game creator is two months away from launch.
And has a lot to do every day.
Okay.
What is this?
Oh.
The mission is to deliver well-balanced nutrition to the game creator.
No way there's a mission.
Colonel!
According to data, the target creator tends to eat irregularly due to being engrossed in game development.
Oh.
When thinking, nutrition is essential.
Oh my god.
There he is.
That's where Calorie Mate Liquid comes into play.
Why is his room so cute?
Additionally, this mission is crucial towards successful game development.
Game development.
Commencing virtuous mission.
Let's reach the target while staying chilled.
Oh.
We gotta stay chilled.
Okay.
Oh.
He's waiting.
He's...
Oh.
Okay.
I have to... Oh no.
My chillness is...
You guys are kind of blocking it.
Hold on.
Oh.
Let me...
Let me move you guys down just a bit.
I'll put you like that.
That should be good.
Now you guys can see how chill we are.
You guys can see how cool and how chill we are.
So how do I play this game?
Okay.
Hold on.
What are these?
I see.
A backlog of plastic models.
It's not like that, Mom.
What does that mean?
Whoa.
Why does it move so ominously?
Plastic models.
There's information that the target game created that giant creature.
It's strangely endearing to look at.
What is this feeling?
Whoa.
Oh.
Ow.
This is bad.
Oh my god.
We have health.
We have health, you guys.
Hold on.
What's this?
At the very least, have a liquid first thing so you can last all morning.
Everybody have a liquid in the morning so you can last, okay?
I think we got to knock this over, right?
Probably.
Wait.
I'm clipping through the walls.
Oh god.
Oh shoot.
Um.
Ah!
Why does it sound like it's so ominous?
Top of the table?
You think it's up there instead?
How do I get up there?
I'm just a can.
Oh my gosh.
The camera.
Oh my god.
We're at 7 degrees Celsius.
Oh.
This isn't going to be chilled at all.
Cat.
You have food.
This is true cat behavior.
Oh wait.
I see it.
Huh.
Oh, a VR headset, huh?
According to data, they've become much lighter in recent years.
This guy, all he's got is calories.
Oh, yogurt flavor.
How are you?
I want to hear.
I want to hear Akio Otsuka say all this.
Oh, is that cafe au lait flavor?
How are you doing?
Why?
Is that cafe au lait flavor?
What else is on here?
Can I chill myself out?
Can I become cool?
Chill.
I'm chill.
Like, put me under the water.
Um.
I went on the stove.
No.
Oh wait.
Maybe...
Oh.
I keep wanting to go faster with it.
What's wrong?
It's a ball.
It's a little play ball.
It's okay cat.
Only cats.
Hands.
What?
Oh, wait.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
I see.
Nice.
What's up there?
His cosplay.
Oh my gosh.
What's wrong?
Oh no.
He is getting isekai?
What's happening?
Super Chanto time.
Oh.
Think about it.
I've heard of this.
You have?
When a game creator's work immersion reaches its limit, the data they're working on can break the fourth wall and invade reality from their computer.
Is that a bug?
I see.
They're swamped with a massive number of bug reports.
Oh, sorry.
Oh, what did I say?
Defeat the bugs.
Oh.
Eliminate the S-Bugs.
Oh my god.
The bugs are delusions, but actual data can be displayed in augmented manner.
Oh, I can't see.
If we eliminate them, the bugs inside the computer should disappear.
I won't give up.
I'm nice and dry, but it's a little hard to move.
You're too loud, Snake.
I give up trying to use you.
Oh, it's my eyes.
My ga - ugh, it's my- my eyes.
Okay.
Time for a little pre-mission exercise.
Camera.
Space.
Okay.
Easy.
And here we go.
All right.
I knew everything.
I already knew everything.
Okay.
The mission is to deliver win- Yeah, yeah.
I know the mission.
So it said we have to defeat the S-Bug, but some of those said, like, A... B...
You think it's timed?
If I'm so chilled, do you think the bug will still happen?
Oh my god!
A bug!
How do I destroy it?
How do I do that?
I'm just a can!
Oh!
I'm too good at this.
I'm too good at this game.
Ouch!
I think I lost health a little bit.
Oh, I'm getting too excited.
I'm just a can, please!
This dialogue.
Please.
Am I doing it?
Am I defeating the monster?
Am I doing it, you guys?
I can't tell!
Don't interrupt the mission!
Am I doing it?
Oh wait, that looks like health.
Yeah!
Oh, I'm stuck.
Ouch!
Oh, okay.
Narrator.
Maybe I need to attack it.
I think so, but I'm just not sure.
Right now, I'm just kinda collecting coins and health and stuff.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
How do I get up there even?
Ugh!
Not yet!
Defeating these is enough.
They don't even come after me.
They just kind of like exist.
They're even bumping into each other.
They're so stupid.
What's happening?
Oh my god!
Okay, how do I get up there?
Maybe... maybe like through the pillow?
Feels like their sleeping posture is quite poor.
Quite poor.
You guys...
Oh, I did it.
Okay.
Nice, nice.
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh.
I'm trying, I'm trying.
Can you not go to the bed?
I'm trying!
Okay, hold on.
If I get enough momentum, I can maybe go up the blanket.
Oh my god.
Do something!
I can't even get up the...
Oh my gosh.
Oh, there you go.
I can't even get up the bed.
No, no!
Oh, that was close.
Okay, hold on.
I think if I... here?
Like this?
And then... no!
Oh no, no, no!
Okay, okay.
Okay,
okay, okay.
You assholes!
All of you!
Oh my god.
Don't interrupt the mission!
Stop!
Please!
Oops.
I got a bit too excited.
Please.
Oh my god!
There's so many of them!
Why are they up there?
Okay.
Hold on.
Oh my god.
Oh, please.
I'm stuck in here.
The Dark Souls.
I need a calorie-based liquido!
Oh my god, please.
Don't come here!
Okay, okay.
Okay.
I should have rolled instead of jump-jumped.
I should have rolled.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, you guys.
We got this.
Calorie Souls.
I might need to get more health though.
Oh.
I won't give up.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Time for a little pre-mission exercise.
Get me out of here.
I'm ready.
And here we go.
Yeah!
Here we go!
I'm ready.
I'm ready for the mission.
See, I thought I was supposed to like...
feed the cat... to... you know...
Okay.
According to all known lies of aviation.
It has a lot to do every day.
Okay, here we go.
Alright, we know what to do, guys.
We know what to do.
Angel!
Thanks for the gift, dude!
Eliminate the S-Bugs!
Eliminate the S-Bugs.
The bugs are delusions, but actual data being displayed in an augmented manner.
If we eliminate them...
Oh, no, no, no, no!
Out!
Why can't I, like, Mario them?
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, okay.
Oh, that was so close!
I can't see!
I can't see, please.
Okay.
Quite impressive, isn't it?
Thank you.
I am quite impressive.
Oh, God.
Please, please, let me move, let me move.
There's more?
We still got S-Bugs?
Where?
We do?
Oh, okay.
And he's now doing stuff down there.
Okay.
Why are there so many bugs in this tiny room and I can't see anything?
There are still some S-Bugs left.
I'll support the creator's debugging work.
Okay.
Can you come down here?
How do I get up there?
No.
What?
This is so messed up.
Please.
Not yet.
No, don't hit me.
Don't hit me.
What's my hitbox?
I'm just a can.
Don't interrupt the mission.
What?
Oops.
I got a bit too excited.
Okay.
I'm trying to get rid of them.
How am I supposed to get up there?
This is bad.
This is bad, man.
This is actually bad.
Yeah.
There we go.
Please.
Box.
No.
Don't be stuck now.
Box.
No.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
No.
Oh,
I can't push it.
Oh, my God.
Where'd the box go?
Wait.
Where'd the...
Oh, my God.
No.
This is so bad.
How am I supposed to climb up there?
If I have no box?
What am I supposed to do?
He has steps?
I guess so.
Okay.
We're making our way up.
Oh, I'm getting hurt, I think.
Oh, I am...
I am getting hurt every time.
Yeah!
I am a gamer!
This game is for gamers only!
Did we manage to eliminate them all?
It seems the bugs have been removed.
Give me... all my treasure.
What does...
There's information that the target game creator tried to work through their backlog of games after yesterday's work.
No!
This is going to disappear!
No, I earned these!
They got into their work and stayed up late and skipped breakfast today as a result.
No!
My coins!
Okay, how am I supposed to get up here now, game?
Okay, tell me this.
You've destroyed all of the boxes.
How am I supposed to get up here?
How am I supposed to...
At the very least, have a liquid first thing so you can last all morning.
Shut up!
Jump at the end?
Oh, let's try it.
We did it!
He's a gamer.
Sometimes lunch ends up being late.
Oh, another cat.
Okay.
What do we do with this guy?
Oh, I think I have to parkour?
Okay.
It's hot here.
I'd like a splash of water, but...
I'll bear it.
Let's get the game creator nourished quickly.
You're... you... why don't you just drink your... self?
You are literally the hydration, are you not?
How are you thirsty?
If you drink me, you can replenish the five essential nutrients your body needs in a well-balanced manner.
What do you mean by that, gallery mate?
You're... you... why don't you just drink your... self?
I see.
You don't like the idea to drink juice, do you?
Yeah, but...
You know, I think you are the one who I want to be with.
I want to be with.
I'm totally down with you.
Oh, wait.
You can drink some juice along with it.
I'm here.
I'm game creator!
I'm here!
Yeah... and?
Mmm...
Oh yeah.
Okay.
Oh my gosh, you guys hand-holding!
The creator's room...
Sounds kind of ominous though, right?
Let's aim for their palm.
How?
Oh!
No!
Oh wait, this is just part 4.
Join the idol club!
Oh my god, let the guy have hop!
What?
This chart!
It's too chaotic!
Are they trying to create an action RPG where school idols thrive in a dark fantasy world?
Looks like things have gotten quite mixed up.
What?
Okay.
Oh.
Start.
The turmoil of youth!
Ouch!
Oh no.
If I die, I probably have to start over at the very beginning, I imagine.
Thank you!
Wait, this kind of slaps.
Join the magic club!
Practice wizardry!
Oh no.
Oh!
This is bad!
Okay, just kidding.
Actual Miku.
Okay, let's join the idol club instead!
Oh, come on!
This is kind of awesome, not gonna lie.
Don't interrupt the mission!
Oops.
I got a bit too excited.
You guys, I can't die.
I can't die.
Okay.
Join the idol club!
Will the idol club be discontinued?
Team development is teamwork.
Oh, here he comes.
Here he comes.
Okay, okay.
If anyone is missing, the team can't perform at its best.
This is so...
Just like the five essential nutrients.
This is too much.
Okay.
Idol club.
Go to an audition!
Ah!
It's mine!
Huh?
The flowchart has changed!
Oh!
Simple gear?
What is happening?
This is kind of awesome!
Um...
Yay!
In fact, one of the origins of Calorie Mate is space food.
It is?
For more details, check the Calorie Mate website.
Oh my gosh.
This is too much.
Check the website.
I'm surviving.
I'm fighting for my life out here, Calorie Mate.
I'm at 13 degrees Celsius.
I'm getting warm, warm, warm.
I'm not a chilled beverage anymore.
Oh!
That was close.
Arrive at the Flame Fort.
Guys, I don't know about this.
Yes!
Go Liquid!
Go!
Oh my gosh!
What is going on?
I have to survive all of this!
Not yet.
What do you mean, not yet?
Am I getting hurt?
Is that hurting me?
To elevate your daily nutritional levels, Calorie Mate Liquid is ideal.
Calorie Mate is stressing me out.
Don't interrupt the mission.
Oops.
I got a bit too excited.
I'm so excited.
What?
There's enemies down here now.
No.
Oh, there's health enemies.
Okay.
Don't interrupt the mission.
They shouldn't be able to hurt you.
Oops.
I got a bit too excited.
Oh my god.
No way.
They hurt you.
Oh my god.
No, no, no, no.
Leave me alone.
Ah!
I can't even see anything.
Please.
I'm gonna die.
Don't bother me.
Don't be at the very beginning, please.
Please.
Don't be at the very...
Okay.
Time for a little pre-mission exercise.
And here we go.
You go.
I wanna go back in here.
You go instead.
Please.
What?
How am I getting hotter with the fridge?
I'm in the fridge.
Oh, no.
I'm gonna die.
This game is brutal.
What the hell?
They were like, yeah, only gamers can play this game for real.
Oh my gosh.
Apples and Bananas.
I don't want to do this again.
Oh my god.
Eliminate the S-Bugs.
The bugs are delusions, but actual data being displayed in an augmented manner.
Oh wait, I'm an idiot.
Sorry.
If we eliminate them, the bugs inside the computer should disappear too.
Okay.
Does it hit here?
I don't think so.
Oh yes, it does.
This is bad.
You guys!
I didn't think that this was going to be a Rage game.
No!
I lost my box.
Are you kidding me?
What is...
Okay.
All right.
To the... Oh my gosh.
To the bench.
To the... Oh, that was close.
To the bench!
Please!
Don't interrupt the mission!
Oops.
I've been a bit too excited.
Please!
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
We still got S-Bugs?
Oh.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Maybe I can get him from down here.
I'm a gamer.
There are still some S-Bugs left.
I'll support the creator's debugging work.
Oh, wait.
But I have to...
Wait.
But I have... I get hurt when I go up him.
Oh, no.
Minto gaming.
Okay.
I don't get hurt on these ones, though.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Don't interrupt the mission!
Don't interrupt him!
Oops.
I got a bit too excited.
Don't interrupt the mission!
Oh my god.
How do I get enough...
I got a bit too excited.
How do I get enough momentum, though?
Did we manage to eliminate them all?
Give me my spoils.
It seems the bugs have been removed.
Are there any health?
None?
Okay.
That's fine.
That's okay.
There's information...
Feels like their sleeping posture is quite poor.
No, please.
Quite poor.
Oh, my...
My...
First try.
What a gamer.
I know, right?
We're gaming.
Oh.
Okay.
We need to go beyond.
We need the full momentum.
I
was trying to...
I was trying to game you guys.
I'll just drink you.
It's not weird at all.
Calorie mate.
Is that a flirt?
Hey, he brought it up first.
Sometimes lunch ends up being late.
What did you guys have for lunch today?
Was it calorie mate and liquid dough?
If not, what are you doing?
If you drink me, you can replenish the five essential nutrients your body needs in a well-balanced manner.
Butter chicken.
Chicken.
McDonald's.
Free barbecue.
I don't think it's 9 a.m.
But what?
Well, what will you have for lunch?
What will you have for lunch then?
During long development sessions, what stays with the creator to the end is nutrition.
Hot dog.
Having dinner, got some soup.
What kind of soup?
Balanced nutrition helps sustain strong performance.
Wow, he just doesn't shut up.
This is something I've heard.
I think this would be so much better if he just stopped doing this.
If I die again, you guys... If I die again, I'm switching the voices, okay?
We'll switch it to Akio Otsuka.
So that we can have Snake talking in our ear instead.
I would leave now, but I don't want to do the boss battles.
Oh my gosh, I think I have that same Tumblr.
Something very similar.
This guy doesn't even have an OPI mousepad.
How much of a gamer are you?
Alright, Hatsune Miku.
Oh, what?
Even the barrier hurts me?
Come on, game.
Don't be like that.
Don't be like that, game.
Please.
Oh my gosh, my health.
I don't think this is the run, you guys, but...
Okay, join the idol club.
Balanced nutrition helps sustain strong performance.
This is something I've heard.
Not...
Huh?
Ah!
The flowchart has changed!
The flowchart!
This part's kind of awesome, I like it.
Okay, someone said there was a shortcut, but...
I... I'm not quite seeing the vision.
Is it like from there to here?
But I can't pass through the pleasure.
I think I have to go.
I actually have no idea where I need to go.
Because you can control your own time, it's easy to become engrossed in production and eat irregularly.
I actually don't know.
Thank you!
Wait, hold on.
Sorry, I can't read the donuts.
There we go.
Liquid calorie mate is liquid snake.
The regular calorie mate is solid snake.
Does that make the jelly calorie mate solid-ish snake?
No, it's literally solid-ish.
Not solid-ish.
It's neither liquid nor solid.
Gosh!
When you reach the checkpoints in this section, it starts an elevator platform that lets you get back part of the way once you fall.
Ah, okay, cool.
Ah, you know...
Wait!
A girl?
Wait, where's...
What?
Oh my god, no, I'm gonna get...
Oh, I see the...
I see it, I see it.
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
This is so hard!
Ouch!
Ah!
It's a girl.
I'm liquid.
Calorie mate liquid.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
I'm liquid.
Calorie mate liquid.
Is this a...
Uh...
What's his name?
Wait, why is there only one voice in the English, but this one...
Yeah, is this Kenjiro Tsuda?
The guy from Jujutsu Kaisen.
What's his name?
Oh my gosh.
Nanami, right?
No.
Why?
I'm liquid.
Calorie mate liquid.
It tastes like a fruit mix.
Nanami!
My favorite character in Jujutsu Kaisen.
That's a hard one.
I'm liquid.
Calorie mate liquid.
It tastes like a yogurt.
She's so cute!
I'm liquid.
Calorie mate liquid.
It tastes like a fruit mix.
I'm liquid.
Calorie mate liquid.
Wait, I knew that.
I knew it was Mikuhito.
I remember seeing the...
Yes, I remember.
Okay.
Yes, yes, yes.
I knew that.
Because I remember them saying who they say you were.
I just forgot about him.
I'm liquid.
Calorie mate liquid.
It tastes like a fruit mix.
I thought the...
Okay.
It's so weird that the English doesn't have different voices then.
Okay, let's go.
Wait,
I'm not gonna skip this.
I'm liquid.
Calorie mate liquid.
I don't remember a single word he said.
I don't remember a word he said.
Who had this inspiration why he goes everywhere.
He was not my history teacher.
He taught me about things The End recently.
...
I...
It sounds so... good.
I'm normal.
I'm normal, I'm normal.
Why do you have to say it like...
Banana to Ringo da.
Okay, I'm normal.
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
Thank you.
Wait.
I think I can get there from here.
Yeah.
Alright, I'm a pro now.
Oh, shoot.
I'm not a pro.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Am I done?
Am I not?
Okay.
I'm a pro, I'm a pro, I'm a pro.
I can't see anything.
Okay.
Ouch!
Not yet.
Come on, get out of my way.
Okay.
Alright.
We're gaming, we're gaming, we're gaming.
Okay.
Parkour, parkour.
Unfair, you!
Unfair!
Unfair, so unfair.
Okay.
So unfair.
Unfair.
Okay.
What the?
I'm losing so much health.
Because of these dang guys.
Oh my gosh.
No, no, no.
Oh my God.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh my gosh, please.
Please!
Oh, nice timing.
Nice timing.
Look at him just staring at...
Ah!
Oh my god!
This guy sucks!
Otsuka's voice coming from the cat is killing me.
It was kind of worth it.
Snake!
I want to know what he says about the other stuff, but we can't get too hot.
Especially because the last area takes so long.
His voice is so cool!
Oh my god, his voice is...
Unfair.
Oh, okay.
Actually, it was maybe a good thing we...
Oh my god!
Stop!
Why isn't there like a...
What's it called?
A cool down.
I should have some eye frames, a little bit.
This is so painful!
Did anybody watch Maddy play this?
How did she fare?
I'm curious.
He pressed space!
What happened?
She finished in 45 minutes?
She's such a gamer.
This game is crazy.
Okay.
Come here.
Yeah!
And then... come here.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh!
Stop!
Don't hurt me!
Oh, shoot.
That was me.
That was all me.
Oh my god, I got double hit.
Guys, I don't think this is a run.
Unless I can get more health.
Which... they only drop sometimes.
Not as often as you think they should.
Buddy, if this is coming from your computer, I think you need some real help, man.
Stop changing your stance mid-jump.
Okay, I'll tell you why I keep doing that.
It's my Minecraft brain.
Okay?
My Minecraft brain tells me shift is run.
Or shift is like go faster.
And so I'm doing it because I'm like, oh, I want to propel.
I want to jump higher.
So I keep pressing shift as if it's gonna make me faster.
So that's why to just give you guys an explanation as to why I am constantly shifting up and down is because I'm using it.
I'm thinking of it as like a go fast.
Go faster.
Because I'm a one-trick pony.
I only play one game.
And it makes me only know controls for a single game, you know?
Yeah, block game brain.
I literally just played it like yesterday.
So I'm just kind of like...
I'm just thinking about it, you know?
Thinking about them beans.
Oh, come on.
Oh, that was...
But sometimes I do it on purpose like that where I want to actually stick the landing, you know?
He screams like you?
Stop.
Stop complimenting me.
Ouch, ouch.
Okay.
That was close.
Actually, that super chat saved me.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay.
Oh...
Betrayed by chat.
Any house in the room?
No, I don't think so.
It's okay.
It's fine.
Okay.
Oh...
Fine.
The aim of the game creator is to try to digest the dishwasher after work yesterday.
Hmm.
Is the health in the room with us?
No.
Okay.
Okie dokie.
Do you think at any point he'll say, you sent to da?
I love how the voices for the guy in Japanese sounds so cool.
But in English, just sounds like the Nintendo Direct dude.
It's like, ah!
Why is that her beat?
Oh my gosh, I'm not trying to escape.
I'm just trying to...
I'm just trying to live, man.
Okay, we'll wait for the night.
We'll wait for the night.
I don't know how I'm gonna get through this.
I'm not even like...
By the time I get to the part where I get to though, I'm not even like halfway through.
It's kind of insane.
I don't know how I'm gonna be able to get through the rest of this.
For real.
Nice.
And she's stuck the landing.
It's the dev of...
Of the Master Collection Volume 2.
Oh my gosh.
Ouch.
Ah!
No!
Ouch!
Why does that hurt me?
Oh my god.
Everything hurts.
Everything...
It's too painful.
Oh my god, the night.
The shortcut?
It's not there!
It wasn't there!
It only appears, I think, once I get to the yellow.
Okay.
Nice.
Wait for it to come back.
Yeah, I have to land on the yellow before I get there.
I have to get the shortcut.
See?
It only appears...
Once I'm there.
I want to make a good game.
That is the important aim of the creator.
Yeah!
Oh, there... See?
See?
There's one.
Okay.
I see it now.
And then it creates another shortcut, I think?
When it comes to Calorie Mate, many people think of the block type.
But in fact, the origin of Calorie Mate...
Okay.
...is actually me.
Ouch!
This is a mistake.
It's just a human being.
I think it saved me.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, come on...
ouch!
What just hurt me...?
Okay.
Checkpoint!
Maybe?
Okay.
I found a checkpoint.
No!
Where does it go?
This is it.
I'm going to be fired eventually.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Where do I go, you guys?
Wait, I don't know.
Where do I go?
Which way is the correct way?
There's green, there's blue.
Follow the green.
To the blue after?
I don't know.
The green, the green, okay.
Wait, what about the checkpoint?
Oh, I see, I see, I see where, I see, I see, I see.
Okay, I see, I see.
Wait,
it takes me to here, okay, okay.
I see, I see.
Okay.
Oh, that was close, that was close.
I don't think it got me.
Drink on the keyboard?
Wait, what do you mean?
Okay.
So this one...
It just...
I think I can just jump from here.
Okay, alright.
Ah!
Now what?
Um, now what?
Where do I go?
Oh, down?
Okay, okay.
Oh my gosh.
I did it!
You guys, this game is unfair.
This game is so unfair.
I didn't even... What are you talking about?
No, no, no, no.
Oh my god.
Why is the octopus just all over the place?
Blinking lights equals bad, okay.
Oh my god, did I just get hurt again?
No way.
The tacos are killing me!
The tacos!
Oh my gosh, there's so many tacos.
Shortcut next to the TV?
I don't see it.
I don't think there is one.
Oh, unless you mean that one right there.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
Why are there so many...
This is... This is so broken!
This is so broken!
I can't get through because of this damn guy!
Oh my... It's Squid Game!
Not Squid Game.
It's... It's Suica Game!
Oh my god, it's Suica Game where the tacos...
If they combine, they become a bigger taco!
No, no, I can't get through!
Oh my god.
No, please, please.
Please.
Oh, I'm gonna die.
Please!
Don't let me die!
I hate the tacos!
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, I can't get through because of these damn guys.
There's too... There's too...
Drop down to blue?
From here?
How do you know which one's blinking?
I can't even...
Oh, I see, I see, I see.
Just go for it?
Lucky.
You think I can make it there?
Oh!
Ah!
Gah!
Oops.
I don't know where I am.
Actually.
I was...
I... I, I don't know where I am.
You guys have one hit and I'm dead.
I have one hit and I'm dead.
Ooh.
Cyrillic grunting noises.
Oh there I am!
There I am.
Oh, it's on top of the table.
Okay, or on top of the TV.
I like how I can avoid pretty much all of this.
Actually, why don't I just do that instead?
I was right there!
What killed me?
Was it one of the little teddy bears?
Was it one of the teddy bears?
Oh my gosh.
Okay, cat.
I wasn't even close to you.
Okay,
cat, it's so funny.
Oh my gosh.
Ouch,
ouch, ouch, ouch.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Don't touch me.
Okay.
Trying to make sure... I can't tell sometimes where they drop, you know?
Yeah!
Help!
You guys were going in with full health.
Okay, we got this.
I don't even need... Actually, let's take my riches.
Let's take my riches before they disappear.
Okay, whatever.
It's fine.
What the hell is this game?
It's fine, though!
I got you!
This is the run.
Don't jinx me, you guys.
Stop it.
Stop talking.
See?!
Stop chatting.
Stop talking.
I'm gonna turn emo only on... I'm gonna turn emo only on...
I don't think you can do that on YouTube.
She hurts us!
Oh my gosh!
What's wrong with me?
Why can't I get it this time anymore?
It's like the easiest part.
See?
It's because you guys kept saying it's the run.
This is not the run.
Exactly.
Okay.
So now we know that from here we can just skip some parts.
Oh my gosh.
Walk away.
Flowchart be damned.
I don't care about a flowchart.
I don't care about the flowchart.
Miku!
Oh
gosh.
Oh gosh.
The camera.
Oh camera.
Yeah!
Oh!
That was so close!
Holy cow!
No!
Uh...
Yeah, I'm just gonna go for this.
Come down, please!
Oh.
Uh...
Come down, please!
Oh.
Uh...
I just gotta be good enough to get it?
Oh my god, oh my god.
Come down, please!
Drink me!
What the- Okay.
Okay!
Stop!
You're gonna flesher me!
Akiyousuka, please!
Oh my god!
Don't say it like that!
Oh my gosh...
I can't see anything.
Okay, hold on.
Oh!
I can't s- Okay, there we go.
Okay.
I can't... this damn camera angle, man!
Oh my gosh, please.
It's the camera angle.
Okay.
Why did I... I'm so stupid.
Oh, it's harder.
The shortcut is actually harder than doing it normally.
I'll be honest.
The shortcut makes it so much more difficult.
Okay.
Nice.
Ow!
What hit me?
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Alright.
We got our little shortcut here.
Okay.
Ouch!
Uh, then this comes down.
Okay.
Alright.
Yeah!
Okay.
Do you think I can make it in yet?
Kotaku!
Welcome to my bishop, thank you!
Oh!
Oh my god.
Ouch!
Wait!
Oh no!
I don't have the shortcut because I never made it to the blue!
No!
Oh!
Oh my gosh!
Stay away from me.
We're gonna have to go through... this way.
Maybe.
If I can even make it.
Oh my gosh!
Oh my god!
Stop!
Oh.
Wait.
No.
Oh no!
Leave me alone!
Green shortcut...
Oh, that's right!
Thank you guys!
I forgot about that one.
Yes, thank you.
Oh my gosh.
Camera angle.
It was...
Why can't I go through here?
Okay.
Sure.
I'm...
Sure, there we go.
What's happening?
No!
Oh my god.
It's so fast!
Go away!
I'm getting too hot.
Oh my gosh.
Please.
You...
Bastards!
Oh my god.
Why does this shortcut suck so bad?
I can't see anything!
It spawns as it hits the ground?
No, it goes up and down.
Does it not?
Oh my god.
See it?
No, no, no.
You have to jump onto it.
Jump from the table.
Yeah, that's probably a better idea.
You're probably smarter than me.
Okay.
Fairy...
Okay?
Yes!
Is it correct?
Oh, I see.
It's okay, we still made it.
I did it.
You rock.
So weird.
Oh my god, this bastard!
Don't come back here.
Don't you dare.
Oh my god.
Okay.
IKIMASU!
Okay, uh...
It's fine.
Just go back around this way.
Oh, okay.
That's fine.
That's why I kind of went for it.
Because the guy was starting to walk by.
The timing was a little... Come on.
The timing was not so great.
The timing was...
Oh my gosh.
The timing was not so good.
I think.
Oh my god.
I'm starting to get too hot.
He's walking back even.
He's gonna come this way!
Dramatic gallery mate.
Okay.
There we go.
Okay, there we go.
I'm getting too hot.
I'm gonna die from heat.
Oh my god.
I know.
What do you mean, why do I have to jump?
What are you saying?
Why do I have to...
Am I doing it improperly?
No, I think I have to jump.
Okay.
Shh.
Ugh!
Wait, help!
This is so bad.
Why can't I break this part?
Unless I...
You can roll across it?
Wait, I thought it was a... Oh my god.
No, no, no, no.
Oh, that was close.
Turn around!
Wait, I can just roll here?
I thought it was a...
I thought it was... wait.
Can I roll here?
Wait, it's a bridge?
I thought it was just...
Wait, this is not... I will...
No, I go through this.
Do I not?
It's a glass path?
No, it's not.
Oh!
That's a gla...
I don't know, though, guys.
I think I'll die more likely doing that.
Why do you think the coins were there?
To jump into the air and get them.
Oh.
Wait, I legitimately thought that that was a path.
I just thought it was...
I'm connected because of the flowchart, but I legitimately thought it was a path you had to jump over.
I legitimately thought that.
How am I goofy?
Do you think if I reach 20 degrees, then it's over?
Do you think that's the degree that I can't reach?
Oh my gosh.
Okay, well, I have to rush for it then.
What?
Why don't you do this to me?
Oh no, I made it to 20, and I'm fine.
I was so close!
Okay, we got this.
I SPEEVE.
I SPEEVE, everybody, I SPEEVE.
I don't SPEEVE.
I don't SPEEVE, actually.
This thing is going to kill me.
It's these things.
I don't speed.
Do you think if I go really fast, it'll work?
Well, I'm going to die anyway, so...
Okay.
All right.
We can get there fast, you guys.
We can get this fast.
We got this.
Okay.
Wait, hold on.
Oh, sorry.
I just messed up my setup.
Hold on.
Okay.
There we go.
Let's go!
This is the run, maybe.
Okay.
I speed because...
I don't know.
Oh, I don't speed.
Guys, I don't speed.
I don't believe anymore.
Snake line for good luck.
I don't know why I don't just like do this.
Oh, that's funny.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
One more guy.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Okay.
It was that easy the whole time.
Look, I like a challenge, okay?
I'm challenging myself.
I have to get better at the parkour anyway.
Anyway, so, why not just make it more difficult on myself all the time, okay?
You guys don't understand my genius.
You don't understand my genius!
4D chess, exactly!
Something you guys are playing, checkers.
I am playing 4D chess.
No!
My spoils!
My riches!
Why do they disappear so fast?
Oh, why did I...
Okay, I'm all topsy-turvy right now.
Oh.
Okay.
Perfect.
Here we go.
You can jump from the bed to the planter table.
Planter table?
Yeah, that's what I did.
Wait.
Isn't that what I did?
Okay.
Oh,
I don't like round table.
I've been upon it for a long time.
Oh, I can see you.
I'll bring you down.
Not bad.
It's just that I don't like round table.
I was lucky on other denen.
You don't like round table.
It's hard to know.
Okay.
I'll put you down.
Alright.
I don't know what you're talking about, the bed to the planter.
There's no planter in here.
Oh, okay, so...
Oh my god!
Oh, I did not expect him again.
Oh my gosh, he scared me.
Oh, please.
Oh, gosh.
I took too long.
I know.
I forgot about him.
I forgot about him, you guys.
Hello?
There we go.
Why do you think I've been jumping through it the entire time?
Like, through these jumps.
Because I thought I had to jump through them every time.
But then it makes sense because I've been...
Really?
Seriously?
Oh, come on.
I don't know, guys.
Okay, my brain works in mysterious ways.
Just let me live.
Or, I'm not living.
I'm dead.
But you know.
Just let me be dead.
In my own way.
Okay.
Oh, ouch, ouch, ouch.
I don't learn my lesson.
And I keep missing this one.
Okay.
We're making the worst game ever!
This game sucks!
What is this flow chart?
Oh, ouch, ouch, ouch!
So rude.
So, so rude.
Pain.
Get some health.
How?
Where?
Sometimes the cats don't drop it, though.
Sometimes I don't drop it.
I disappoint Snake.
I disappoint everybody, okay?
I've disappointed my mom.
I've disappointed my...
My family.
Who's to say that...
You know, Snake is just another person on the list to disappoint.
Is this what you call a cat?
There is hope.
Will you prepare for the mission, move around, and make a sound?
The cat just took me out!
You guys, I have to be bad at the game also because otherwise it would be like such a short stream, you know?
You guys don't want that, right?
Oh, I'm done with the stream.
See you later.
Oh shoot.
Ouch!
Oh gosh.
I can't see anything!
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
I lost a lot of health there.
You assholes!
You're all assholes!
Okay.
Wasted my health.
Oh, whoa.
Thank goodness that...
Ah!
Ouch!
Phew.
Any health?
Yippee!
I don't think the bug should...
be able to, like, change between coins and health.
I'm just saying.
Or if you collect a certain amount of coins, you get more health or something.
Like 50.
I can get 50.
Oh wait, you mean from this side I can jump onto this bug plan or...
plant... plant bugger... wait.
This bug...
Wait.
To the table!
She's malfunctioning.
Oh
my gosh.
You guys.
I'm so...
I'm so cooked.
I'm so cooked right now.
Oh my gosh.
Wait a second.
Can't I just sneak?
Oh no.
Okay.
There's a thing right there.
Ugh.
So funny.
She just thinks...
Oh wait.
Just kidding.
Okay.
Are you okay?
Is the heat getting to you?
With some...
Oh my gosh.
Oh my...
Oh!
Ouch!
No!
You guys, I'm regressing.
Truly.
I'm regressing.
I didn't know that I was gonna be touching his heels.
That's so unfair.
Jump across from the arm of the couch?
Like here?
Let's see.
Oh my god.
Yeah, I need the rolling though.
Oh my gosh.
Go, go, go.
I always overdo it.
Touching the wall is diabolical.
The fact that that gets you points off.
Like...
We need to trigger the...
We need to trigger the cutscene.
Okay, let's go back now.
We broke the sequence of events.
So we need to go back.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Go!
Ahhhh!
Uwaaah!
Okay.
Worth.
Worth, worth, worth.
No...
Hey.
So worth.
We hadn't gotten that one yet.
Can I stand on the little blue part?
I don't want to try it though.
It was worth it for that.
Wasn't it, you guys?
Oh!
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
See?
I think it's easier to jump through, that's why I keep jumping.
Oh my gosh.
OUCH!
Thanks,
I guess.
Oh my god!
Oh!
Please!
It's so unfair.
Come here, little heart cat!
Come here!
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Maybe another heart cat will come over here.
Come over here, your coin cat.
I don't need you.
Heart cat!
Come here, heart cat!
And we got the checkpoint, I think, by the...
By the... couch, right?
I don't see it, though.
I got a checkpoint, but...
Heart cat!
Heart cat, come here!
Come here, heart cat!
Oh my gosh.
Go away.
Banana!
Nana!
Where's the heart cat?
I'm just gonna wait, I'm just gonna wait.
Okay, okay, okay.
Come here, come here, heart cat.
Come here, heart cat.
Two heart cats!
Come here!
Oh!
Two heart!
No!
Come here!
Yes.
Okay.
We'll keep collecting hearts, you guys.
I'm not gonna die.
I refuse.
Come here, heart cat.
Hey!
Why are there so many coin cats?
Oh, wait.
I can't wait for too long, because I'm gonna get hot.
Okay, I'm just gonna go for it, then.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Hey!
Okay, I got it anyway.
Nice, nice, nice.
Wait, where's my checkpoint?
Didn't I get a checkpoint on the couch?
Didn't I get a couch checkpoint?
Or no?
Didn't I?
I thought I did.
What happened?
Yellow one on the left?
Huh?
No, I didn't...
I thought I reached it.
Sorry, I got... I didn't know which one to do.
This one.
Okay.
I know I kinda did it backwards, but that's okay.
It's fine.
Okay.
Alright.
Yeah!
Yaaaaah!
Fine,
I'll just use you.
The fire is so mean.
I know!
I shouldn't even exist!
I shouldn't!
Okay.
You... you can avoid the fire.
You can.
How?
I don't...
I don't know.
How am I supposed to avoid that?
I don't know what hit me, but whatever.
Okay.
Okay, we made it, we made it, we made it.
Okay, here we go.
Okay.
And there's healthier.
Yeah!
Okay.
Oh.
All right.
I'm gonna try again.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
I can read.
I know what it just says.
What if I just jump through?
What if I just jump through, you guys?
Oh, jeez.
I should have just jumped.
I forgot he walks over there.
It's okay, it's okay.
Oh, ouch.
Not bad.
Ouch.
Ouch, real.
Hoi!
Oh, here he comes, here he comes.
My depth perception!
You guys, I don't think I can do that with my depth perception, okay?
I'll be honest.
This is a sin game, right?
Sin game.
Oh, ouch.
Just go?
Okay.
I'm just gonna go.
I gotta go fast.
I'm gonna go fast, okay.
We're gonna go fast, we're gonna go fast.
Okay we're gonna go fast, we're gonna go fast, we're gonna go fast.
No!
Okay, hold on.
We gotta wait for him.
Oh my gosh!
Please stop touching me!
Oh my god.
Guys, that was not good.
Okay, I have an idea.
I have an idea.
Never mind.
Stop between the hammers.
That's what I'm saying, my depth perception.
I don't think I can.
Yeah, I know my health is low.
I know.
If I change like this, maybe?
Oh gosh.
Okay, let's health cat.
Health cat!
It's octopus!
Oh my gosh.
You guys, we almost just died for real.
Oh, please, please, please, health cat!
Yes!
I'm stuck.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Good thing there was a health cat there.
Okay!
One more time!
Okay.
I can't, I can't align!
I can't align!
Health cat!
Health cat.
We'll wait for one.
I think that's a health cat over there, but it looks like he has coins.
And he's also gone.
Maybe he's just gotta run it?
I don't...
I don't think so.
I don't know.
Health cat, come here!
No coin cat!
Any health cats in chat?
That's one warm drink.
Yeah, it's getting pretty toasty.
How is it so warm?
What degrees does this guy have his apartment at?
I'm too afraid to go over there, because I'll get killed by the octopus.
I know I will.
Come here!
Okay.
All right, all right, all right.
Fight!
It's giving me, like, stats.
Thank you, snake.
Oh
no, I have to hurry again?
Okay.
This is so unfair.
This guy!
Okay, I'm just gonna go.
I'm just gonna jump for it again.
I'm gonna go.
I'm gonna run for it.
Never mind.
I'm about to die again.
Oh, guys.
If I don't get a health cat, this is it.
This is it.
Oh.
Fight!
Oh, come on.
No!
Why
are the health cats so few and far between?
Why are there not... there's not enough health cats.
Oh.
Fight!
It's that guy's heals.
The guy's heals keep hitting me, so I gotta, like, actually not go when he's around.
I hope the devs of this game aren't gonna make a War of Calamity.
No, I'm actually having fun.
It's just a little tricky.
Tricky doesn't mean bad, right?
Yeah.
Woo!
Oh, crap.
Okay, here he comes.
Oh.
Gosh.
Argh!
I didn't move!
I didn't!
I didn't move.
And he's still hitting me.
Oh.
I didn't even move.
But he went past me.
And then he went past me again and hit me.
How does that make any...
Saint!!
Oh my god!
Health Cat!
We're at 25 degrees.
This guy is pro... 26!
This guy is gaming in the midsummer.
Minto's depth perception.
I'm telling you, I don't have good depth perception!
I don't!
That's always been my enemy!
I'm gonna wait for him to leave.
I wonder how far we can go, you know?
How hot we can go.
H-O-T-T-O-G-O.
How hot can we go?
Oh!
Ah!
I
was fine until you... until the dragon...
Fuck it, I'm just gonna keep going.
No!
Wait!
No, no!
I panicked because the guy was coming back.
H-O-T-T-O...
H-O-T-T-O-G-O.
How hot can we go?
It's gotta be like 30 degrees, probably.
I get it, Snake.
I get it.
Oh!
Hahahaha!
It's not...
I think I got hit by the fire.
Oi moi!
No, it's your birthday!
Is it actually Ducky's birthday too?
Oh, wait.
I'm confused.
Why are you guys in cahoots with each other?
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday oi moi Ducky.
Woo!
Oh!
Unfair.
I called cheat.
I called cheating.
Cheater.
Popkinator.
The game is cheating.
Oh!
Oh, actually that... that one helped me.
Okay.
Did you beat all of them?
Yeah, I did.
Looks like the bug problem has been solved.
Ah!
Boing!
H-O-T-T-O-G-O How high can we go?
Woop!
Boop-boop!
Oh!
Wait, I'm silly.
There we go.
Hah!
Hot!
This game is so... it feels so summer, but...
Part of the reason I'm like a little... a little crazy cookie is right before stream I had a...
Oh!
Oh, the cat's not that close.
I had a coffee.
And I went and got a pumpkin coffee.
Because I'm so excited for pumpkin fall.
I know.
I should have had a calorie mate drink.
Maybe I'm being punished.
I'm being punished for not having had a calorie mate drink.
Now I know I need to like...
Go back here.
But what's wrong with sequence breaking and avoiding...
Oh!
Dang it!
I didn't...
I have to remember the little damn puppets.
These stupid plushies.
I forget they're there because I can jump here, you know?
Okay.
Ah!
The dragon flames is so unfair.
I think after a certain point, you shouldn't have to deal with it anymore.
That's just me.
That's just my thinking.
Like here?
Like that's...
That's a little...
That's a little rough.
Okay.
I think he's gonna get me again.
So I gotta jump.
Okay.
And...
Oh!
Okay.
Ha!
Nice suit!
Oh!
I...
I got hurt.
Wait.
It's okay.
Okay.
Speed thrill.
But we...
I got the strat, though.
I got the strat.
It took me some time, but I have the strat for this part.
I just gotta go as a tall man.
Oh!
Yeah!
Okay.
Oh, gosh.
Here he comes.
Wait.
Oh!
Oh, no!
Oh.
What hurt me.
What hurt me!
Okay.
Yeah!
It was so...
In the end, it was so easy!
It pisses me off!
In the end, it was so easy.
It makes me angry.
How much I could avoid!
In the end, it was so...
It was so easy!
It was so easy.
In the end I like sped right in front of you!
I got a B?
I got a B!
Oh see my time!
Hold on, hold on, hold on.
Look!
I got an S on my time!
And my temperature!
Oh my gosh!
What's the second one here?
Robot?
Face?
What is that?
Speedrun that's my time baby!
S for slow.
I almost spelled sad.
Oh robots are the bugs.
Oh so since I only killed 7 I got a D.
Wait world ranking...
I'm below a thousand.
The world record is 53 seconds?
That is... how?
How?
That's the... how?
That does not even seem possible.
She was purposefully throwing.
How is that the...
How?
Look up a video?
Hold on let's go back to the title.
Does it show the...
Oh.
Wait what's the balloon jump?
I didn't even see any balloons.
What is the balloon jump?
We didn't even get to try the balloon jump.
Because...
What does it mean by that?
In the first part...
Okay as much as I love you.
Otsuka Akkyo.
I'm a liquid.
Calorie made liquid.
It's going to be a busy day.
Oh my god his voice is smooth as butter.
Okay balloon jump.
Oh is it that?
Oh I think I see it.
Oh sorry I was so...
I'm conditioned to...
There's a balloon up there!
I think that's it.
Okay.
Tentsudaya.
Oh my god he sounds so good.
I tried it.
I tried the balloon jump.
Where's my achievement?
I tried it.
I tried to do it.
Where's my achievement?
I tried it.
How far back do you think we need to be?
Like here?
There's a calorie made up there.
Do I... maybe I go through here?
Do I...
maybe I go through here?
Dio?
No Dio is Norio Wakamoto, isn't it?
Dio is someone different.
I see.
Ta-da!
Koyasu?
Oh.
Why did I think it was Norio Wakamoto?
Takehito Koyasu.
Oh just kidding.
I attempted.
Do you think I could get that too?
I don't even know how.
Um.
I'm not here to try.
I'm gonna try all the... here.
Sounds so cool.
Do you think I can go in here?
Where's my achievement for being in here?
Beep.
Boop boop.
Oh is that how you get out?
Oh my god I'm smelling his feet.
Oh yeah.
Wait.
This should be...
Not.
Stinky shoes.
Uh.
I'm stuck.
I'm stuck in here.
Why?
Wait is there another balloon?
Oh no.
That's a...
What is that?
Oh there's another.
There's a second balloon.
Wait how does...
How does Miku say it?
Oh wait I have to change the can.
That's right.
How does she say it I wonder?
That's the same balloon?
Oh did I hit it over there?
My bad.
I'm liquid.
Calorie mate liquid.
Yogurt flavored.
So cute.
You know as much as I love Oscar Akio.
Kind of sick of listening to old men.
My ears are refreshed.
Honestly though all the seiyuu they chose for this are...
Perfection.
I saw... I saw...
Miku Ito recently.
Even the English one?
I wanna see what she says.
My ears are refreshed, my ears are refreshed.
I feel so hot.
I really do.
How cute.
So cute.
Yeah like...
Boring...
It's just...
Oh, they respond!
In the Japanese version, they resp... they respond!
Oh my gosh.
No way.
Oh, because it's voiced by... oh my gosh, it's voiced by the guy, so it's... so it's the brother.
Wait, she's so cute!
She's so cute!
Not goal, Guru!
Makes me wanna say Guru after everything.
Pan fry the calorie mitt.
Yeah, I'll drink you.
I'll drink you up!
Now we're nice and hidden.
Aww, she sounds so sweet!
She's so cute!
Well guys, this is fun.
This is a game for sure.
This is a game for sure, huh?
Cute girl.
I know, cute girl.
I wanna see if they all have... you know how, like, the other cans responded?
I wanna see if that also happens in this one.
I'm a liquid!
Come on, let's go!
We didn't get a matasedana or a... or a issensu da, but we did get...
A liquid!
Which to me was also kinda worth it.
We did get that.
Which was pretty worth it to me.
Banana and an apple.
Why does he say it so sensual?
Oh, yogurt flavor.
How are you?
What about this one?
Oh, I didn't think of that.
According to the information, the game creator's goal is to...
Oh, cafe au lait flavor.
How are you?
There's not one for him though.
It's up there.
How will we even get up there?
Okay guys, we have to... this is our goal.
We have to figure out how to get up there.
Because then we can talk to his own kind.
How do we get up there?
Maybe it needs to be their flavor?
Yeah, maybe, maybe.
How?
How do we...
climb the utensils?
Oh, okay, okay.
Oh, I don't know.
I just left the...
I just left that area for some reason.
I just wanted to look around.
Okay.
I think I can go from here.
Like I can reach it.
Oh, I see what you mean.
I see what you mean.
Dang it.
Balloon?
We already did the balloon.
I'm too good at this game.
Clearly.
Clearly, I'm too good at this game.
Oh.
Okay.
I'm done being cocky.
I'm sorry.
I'm done.
This has got to be also a challenge though.
To meet the green one.
You know?
It doesn't suit you?
What?
Being cocky?
What are you talking about?
Oh.
Hey,
what does he say here?
Oh.
Are you guys sure about this?
Okay.
Oh.
This might be the real final boss.
Oh my gosh.
If I could see anything.
The last thing you need to do with the creator is nutrition.
The five nutrients.
Protein, fat, sugar, vitamin, and minerals.
Take these five nutrients in a balanced way.
What did I say?
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh, please.
Please, please.
You're in the way.
I think I have to turn sideways there.
Probably.
Liquid!
The microwave hallway?
But it's...
Where do you guys see a microwave at?
There's no microwave here?
Oh, above the fridge?
Oh my gosh.
I could just get here more easily.
Oh my gosh!
It actually slides you off.
It's so slippery.
There's like a physics here.
See how I'm sliding?
I can't get the momentum!
Oh, I was on it!
Okay.
How do you think I can get here?
Oh, I wonder if I can go the other way, maybe.
From the microwave, right?
Like if I go from the table to the air con... or the... the... that?
This is important to me.
Okay, I'm gonna try over there.
So close.
I know.
No.
Liquid.
You're not liquid, though.
You're sorry, though.
Actually, I don't know who does the voice of liquid in Japanese.
Oh, no.
I don't think I can go this way.
No!
Oh, get on...
Well, I tried earlier.
It's a bit tricky.
I'd have to maneuver.
Let me see.
Because, like, there's...
Why is everything... Why am I so slippery now?
Is it because I went in the pan?
Ah, behind!
You guys are so smart.
What would I do without you?
No!
Okay.
Slippery snake.
I have a feeling that I have the answer!
I can't... I can't...
Oh, gosh.
I have 11 kinds of vitamins.
Half of them are necessary for the whole day.
Wait.
Oh.
Why does it feel easier from the start?
This is the other side than this side.
Yeah, I got to roll it for sure.
Okay, at least it's easier to get back on.
Oh my gosh, I can actually see outside.
I'm stuck.
Wait.
Okay, there we go.
Why is this so tricky?
It's either... Oh my gosh.
It's either having an easier time getting up here and being able to attempt the jump or having an easier jump.
I want to just try a little bit more.
A little bit more, you guys.
A little bit more.
If the camera angle also wasn't so awful...
It is really tricky.
The door blocks it, but the door blocks it on the other side too.
According to the information, some game creators sometimes don't understand why they have to do this.
So close.
Okay, jumping earlier.
Jumping earlier, everybody.
Oops.
Jumping earlier.
Okay, okay, okay.
This shit looks impossible.
It's not.
But I keep hitting the... I keep hitting the cabinet.
I keep hitting the cabinet.
I keep hitting that corner.
I
didn't jump soon enough.
Sorry, guys.
I'm stubborn.
I'll run to the game creator as soon as possible.
Oh, how are you doing, comrades?
No problem.
They sounded so cute.
Yippee.
Even if my nutrition is not balanced, it is not good to skip meals.
I am king of the kitchen.
Oh, sorry.
I'm blocking it.
My bad.
I forgot to move out of the way.
I'm so sorry, you guys.
What kind of game are you making, game creator?
Okay, one last thing now.
One last thing now.
I'm Liquid.
It's going to be a busy day.
We now have to hear what he sounds like when he meets his buddies.
I'll move slowly.
Oh, wrong way.
Which is easy.
We can get there very easily.
Let's get started.
Today's mission is to deliver balanced nutrition to the game creator in the northeast of this 2DK.
You sound so good.
The goal of the game creator is to dominate the game.
His meals tend to be irregular.
You sound so good.
Okay.
Hoi.
All right.
His buddies are over there.
Bananas and apples.
Hoi.
Young women age into old men.
What are you talking about?
You are talking about me.
Yo.
What's up?
Bocchi bocchi.
Okay.
I feel satisfied now.
I feel satisfied.
Bocchi bocchi.
Wait, hold on.
I don't want to see what the other...
Oh.
What are the other things?
I didn't expect this to be a rage game and I'm not going to play it again.
I didn't expect to have the Mecha Musume Miku.
Great job rolling tonight.
Thanks!
Me neither!
That was so awesome!
Jumping professional.
Try jumping the balloon.
Wait, how do I get...
How do I show... How do I... Oh!
Oh, here we go.
Okay.
Try touching the giant creature.
Oh, that's the cat.
Touch the box of plastic models.
Wait, there's...
According to data, many creators have been asked this question by their guardians.
Did you buy the same kind of model kit again?
Creators who dislike cats don't exist?
We, Liquid, support creators who strive to reach new heights of fun in their creations.
Aww!
Get the creator to drink me.
One problem solved!
Crush 100 bugs in one playthrough.
Clear the game tent.
Achieve an S rank in your overall score.
Oh!
I feel like...
Liquid King.
I feel like I was close-ish.
I got a B.
But I have 10 out of 21.
It's not bad.
Wait.
Oh, there's more over here!
Okay.
Find and crush S bugs.
Get to the creator's room.
Try touching Famitsu.
Oh no, I didn't touch it.
Collect 1000 coins.
Stand on all flowcharts.
Oh.
Reach the goal with no damage.
Guess that's it.
Oh wait, there's more here.
Yellow Phoenix.
Overcome 50 game overs.
What do you mean, overcome 50?
What does that mean?
It was an S rank to us.
Thank you.
It's
our win.
1 and under 50.
Yippee!
At least it's...
I'm so curious what my number is though.
Oh, my eyes!
This is fun, you guys.
I hope you had fun.
I hope you are inspired to drink calorie moat now.
I think I will see next time when I'm just enjoying it.
When I'm in Japan next week, I will get a liquid calorie mate and I will report back how it is.
Hopefully I can drink it.
I'll see if it's carbonated first.
If it's carbonated, then I'll let you guys know.
If it's not, then I will...
What's the word?
Not have it.
Obviously.
Can you play a retro game called Cool Spot someday?
Cool Spot?
I've never heard of it, but thank you.
I'll look into it.
Thanks for the recommendation.
Thanks for the funny Kusuge stream.
Thank you!
And of course I will be drinking the fruit flavor.
Spank!
Thanks for the tank gifter!
Danku!
It doesn't mention carbon dioxide in the content.
Oh.
Maybe it's okay then.
I guess we'll see.
I want to play... what was it?
There's a Doom mod.
Oh, but it's like for a cereal.
I can't remember.
I want to play that one.
I think it's a cereal.
Burger King stealth game?
No way.
Wasn't there like a McDonald's one too?
Chex Quest!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Chex Quest.
I want to play that one.
Maybe we can have a day of just like...
going through strange...
food...
restaurant crossover games.
You know?
Maybe I'll do that.
Pepsi... Pepsiman!
Kusuge ad games.
Yeah, exactly.
There was one recently of the...
of the purple guy from McDonald's though, wasn't there?
I can't remember it.
Grimace.
Yeah, the Grimace game.
Wasn't it a platformer?
Oh, no.
It's the skateboarding.
I think.
Am I crazy?
Yeah, it was a Game Boy game.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
William Afton?
The KFC... The KFC dating sim?
How long is it actually?
How... Hold on.
How long to beat KFC game?
One and a half hours.
Thank you for the fun and pro gaming stream!
Have lots of fun!
Yippee!
Thank you!
I'm so excited for the sign!
Sign!
Try Princess, thank you!
You should live react to the Calorie Mate speedrun.
Oh, yeah, let's see it.
Let's check it out.
Hold on, let me get it up.
Let me get it up.
One second.
Here, let me move you guys back.
To the corner with you!
Um...
Calorie Mate... Wait, oh, why did I exit?
Okay, Calorie... Calorie Mate speedrun.
Um...
Oh, wait, I wrote the wrong thing.
Cal... Cal... Cal...
How do I find it?
Who...
Who do you recommend?
Gotta play Sneak King.
I know, some other people are bringing it up.
Moira Masu!
Welcome to membership, thank you!
Who's the creator that did it so quickly?
Do you guys know the name of the speedrunner?
Oh, wait!
I found it!
RTA 53 seconds.
Yeah, yeah, I found it.
I found it immediately.
After I asked.
Okay.
Give me one second...
Let me...
Pull it up...
Window capture...
It's not perfect.
Good enough.
Maybe.
Good enough, maybe.
Okay, this is from ND606.
It says their speedrun is 53 seconds.
Do they talk in it?
Okay, here we go.
This is not me, this is a speedrun.
This is a speedrun.
Oh, okay.
Alright.
Oh my god!
That's how you can do it!
Oh my god, you can distract him with the bomb!
So he basically... I did the same strats here.
It's really loud.
I did the same strats here.
Oh.
Wow, he even gets up there before the guy is there.
Oh my god!
Yeah!
Oh.
What?
Oh my god!
Okay.
I'm so curious about this part the most.
Oh!
They're not even first, they're 43rd!
Oh my gosh!
They're not even first!
They're not even first.
You guys have to watch this video.
Of Cinnamoroll.
Singing...
43rd.
That's so messed up.
Also, this is the best... I found a new...
I found a new Fujisan live cam.
And look at this!
Look how beautiful!
Hold on, let me show you.
Let me show you the sunrise.
Look!
I need to go here.
I need to go to this place.
Isn't it so beautiful?
I'm so sad though.
Because my usual Fujisan cam has been blurry for the past like two weeks.
So I've been like...
But I found this one.
And I found actually another one that was so, so, so good.
Oh my gosh, I need to go to here.
I need to go to this place.
It looks so beautiful.
Oh my gosh.
I've just been like...
There was...
And then...
The other day...
The other day, there was Fujisan here, right?
And then over here was like a storm.
There's a storm incoming.
And then...
So you could see like all the thunder and lightning and stuff.
It was crazy.
I should have taken a video of it.
Oh man, that was so awesome.
Kuwabara, Kuwabara.
Sounds good for a living retirement place.
No!
Because...
On this mountain...
You can't...
Are they moving?
Why are these...
Oh, yeah.
They're just really still.
On this mountain, you can't use soap.
Or shampoo.
Fly over to wipe the lens of the blurry one.
I know, I really should.
You can't use soap to preserve the waters in the mountain.
You can't use soap.
Isn't that crazy?
If I went, you guys would actually be able to call me stinky.
You'd be like, oh my gosh.
Mints on the mountain.
She can't wash herself properly.
Stinky, stinky, stinky.
Imagine what all the people that live on the shrine smell like.
Do you get used to the stench?
Or is it just because it's so breezy all the time?
You never smell anybody.
I wonder.
But look at this.
Isn't it just gorgeous?
I can't wait to see what it looks like in winter.
Because then you'll get like the little ice cap on top.
I'm so excited to see.
And then I wonder if the other mountains will be a little bit snowy too.
But I wonder if you can go in winter.
If the snow will be too harsh.
I don't know.
Well, I mean for myself, you know.
Mint, why would I imagine the smell?
Because I'm curious.
Hold on.
Let me see if I can find the other Fujisan camera that I found.
Here, I'll show you.
I'll show you.
Okay.
This is the one I usually use.
Look at this.
It's so sad.
It looks like I have my glasses off.
It sucks.
It's so sad.
It's so bad.
I know.
Yeah.
So, this is the one I've used for like years even.
But then I found this one today or the other day.
And so, look how beautiful.
Look at the colors and everything.
So, I'll use this one from now on.
Yeah.
It's so pretty.
So, so pretty.
It looks like a painting.
I know.
So pretty.
Yeah.
What's this?
Haneda live cam.
They stream from 9 AM.
Fujisama Kamiyoshi.
I know.
Is this right now?
It says it's live.
920.
That's today.
Well, it's in Japan.
That's right now.
Wow.
Oh, no.
Why did I find this?
I'm going to be watching this all the time now.
Oh, no.
Like.
They're like so cute.
Speaking of my ear.
Time to stream yourself landing at the airport.
Okay, you guys.
I'm going to give you my exact time.
No, I'm just kidding.
I'm going to tell you exactly when I fly.
Is there a Narita one?
I'm going to tell you exactly when I fly in.
And I'll say, okay, look out for me.
Yeah.
Look at them.
Oh.
Are they?
Did they just land?
Wait.
Oh, my gosh.
This person is like work in the camera.
Nope.
No, they're taking off.
Oh, my gosh.
This is so awesome.
They go.
Oh, my gosh.
The wings.
Wow.
Bye.
Oh, my gosh.
There goes the.
There goes the tires.
This cat.
Is this their job?
To just run the camera.
I want this.
Look at this job.
Is that Skytree over there?
So foggy.
So smoggy.
Yeah, they are doing a great job.
I just turned back.
Why are we watching the Tokyo airport?
Cuz I wanna.
I just checked the flight tracker.
It's live.
That's so awesome!
Wow, I guess these... I wonder if they are domestic flights.
It's all A&A.
That one was JAL, but...
Yeah, you do your job, mister.
It's just controlling the camera.
Alrighty.
I don't wanna get copyright struck by Haneda airport.
I'm having flashbacks to... I'm having flashbacks to Spy Animals.
Which if you know, you know.
The BBC.
You guys, I have a permanent copyright strike on my account because of the BBC.
Because I showed Spy Animals and they didn't like that.
And then I got copyright struck.
It was... No, not the plastic crabs.
It was the monkey.
I work for a cargo facility that works directly with JAL.
You could be on here one day.
Maybe.
They didn't want the truth getting out.
Don't Google Spy Animals.
I was letting out... I was letting spy government secrets to my stream.
I had like... Oh my gosh.
It also annoys me.
I had like... I don't know.
Like less than a hundred viewers.
And they still targeted me so hard.
They're like... They're like the world will find out.
The world will know.
Oh man.
Yeah, messed up.
So messed up.
That's okay.
I can track your flights.
No!
Don't track my flights!
You know what you did to those monkeys.
Yeah, the Patriots.
I just wanted to watch Spy Animals.
I was so excited.
Okay, I'm done for real now.
Thank you guys for hanging out with me.
Thanks for allowing me to do a little Fuji update.
Here, we'll go back to it.
Hold on.
Wait, where's the other one?
Oh, this one.
Oh, no, not that one.
This one.
Thanks for allowing me to Fuji update you guys.
And I discovered another live cam and that's dangerous.
Thank you so much for hanging out with me and letting me play silly calorie mate game.
I totally gamed it for sure.
I'm going to try the speedrun strat.
I actually am so curious if I could pull it off.
Like though at the very end like that.
It was so goofy and silly and fun.
And yeah.
Otsuminto.
And I will see you guys later.
Itterashai.
Bye-bye.
Haruka, welcome back.
Thank you.
Bye-bye.